trong sức quá trình lãnh đạo kích nạc, đảng ta vẫn dụng sáng tạo tương tượng của chỉ biết về đại đại đoàn kết tạng rất tộc.
Khi định quan điểm rất là lo, tăng bỏ ở nhân dân, tăng cường đực phật giúp ta dài tần, rất tổng,
tổng giáo và người bên nà mà đúng ngoài, xây dự khối đoạn kết thống nhất ý chi, thành động.
Trong nhận kia qua, đảng nhà nước đã trích tục bán hành và trình hay đồng bộ các chủ chương, chí sách,
tạo nên tạo nền tạo chăm để phát vị xương mạnh đại đồn kết bản rất tổng.
Nêm tín hồi nhân dân đối với đảng, thông nhà nước này cảnh đu cùng của
đing hần đoàn kết, tương thương đối, chắc nhận cộng đồng này tiếp quân được lãnh tỏa.
Sức mạnh tổng học, chồi nhân dân đối phát vị mạnh mạnh trong công cuộc sây dựng vào bảo vệ tổng.
Con kinh định mặt trật tổng của Việt Nam, các tổ chức chính chỉ sợ, và các tổ chức thành viên, ngày càng phát vị tốt này cho đại diện.
Bảo vệ quyền vào lợi ít thợ pháp, chính đáng của nhân dân, thẳng định bị chi,
cầu nấu tin cạnh giữa đảng, nhả nước và nhân dân, thông qua việc thăm ra dây dân và hoàn thiện thể chế,
chính xác khác lột tổ chức các phản đậu giám xác phản biệt só hội, kết sức người chi và đối thoại chực tiếp,
qua các tây giám xác của mặt trật tổng quốc, nhân dân đất tích cộng thăm ra, phản ánh nhất cộng
chẳng khoản lý và thực thi công vụ, cùng các thông tin để xúc các tổng quan chức năng,
kết thời sự lý nhiều bánh này vụ việc này xinh trong thực thiễn, qua đó,
vai trò của nhân dân, trong phòng trống thăm nhúng là phí tiêu cửc được phátuis,
có phẩn tích cửc trong công tác xây dựng nạn và hệ thống chính trị.
Với quan điểm lời nhân dân làm chúng tâm, gắn phát triển kinh tế xá hội với việc đáp ứng lợi kết thực của nhân dân.
Hở lúc nào hết, mặt trận tổ quốc cần phát vị cao đậu mai trò lên mình chỉ chỉ,
khiến hệ tựng vệ của các tổ chức chính trị, các tổ chức chính trị xá hội,
tổ chức xá hội và các cá nhân tiêu biểu.
Vào các tổ chức hình.
Kết thục nổi mỗi mạnh mẽ, quan vệ lộ dung phương tích và kơi trễ hoạt động,
lấy các vấn đề, vấn sình, vấn trủ, làm trọng tân,
nâng cám chức lượng lộng mũ cán bộ, nhất là độ mũ cán bộ mặt trận tổ quốc,
các tổ chức chính trị xá hội ở cơ sở, kẹt tòàn và thành hệ thống tổ chức thông môi mấy,
và kết thử chế với họ, kết hướng, một mỗi mỗi, mỗi thời hà, một kết quả,
đồng thời nâng cao chất lượng hợp lượng gám sát và bệnh sợi,
mặt trạc tổ quốc Việt Nam tiếp tục trủ chế,
tổ chế các trưng trình gám sát, phản bệnh sợi, trong phạm viên toàn quốc,
lối với những vấn đề thiết thượng, các sự thảo lật và các vấn vấn mạnh,
quy phản phóng lật theo quý định, làm bảo thiệu quả thực chắc.
Đại đoàn cách là giá chị chuyện hồn quy bấu,
và lần nhân tổ quýết định mọi thống lợp của giống tổ ta,
sinh hời, chú tên hộ chi Minh đã khẳng mực trinh lý,
trong bầu trời không gì quả nhân dân trong kẻ dưới không gì mạnh bằng lực lượng đàn cách của nhân dân,
và đàn cách, đàn cách, đàn cách, đàn cách,
hành công, hành công, đàn hành công, đàn hành công,